les chers collègues la question
s'adresse à monsieur véran doit être
confiné et donc ça va s'adresser à
monsieur taquet mais plus généralement à
tous les ministres qui se sentent
concernés dans la lutte contre le coc
vite 19 et ce qui ne manquera pas d'être
une épidémie js aussi évidemment mes
collègues de l'oise du mort vivant ou et
de la haute savoie qui vont être
concernés par la question
l'oise un quotidien titre les rues se
vident la désorganisation et la wii
quoi qu'en ait dit le gouvernement
pendant un mois et demi il y avait un
préparation à avoir cette crise quoi que
vous en ayez dit nous le vivons chaque
jour dans l'oise où on improvise qu' une
fermeture d'école de faire venir telle
ou telle classe je veux comme exemple
les masques qui ont été dits on les
libère 15 millions de masques ça a été
répété ils sont disponibles pour les
professions médicales depuis hier car
dans cette pseudo préparation vous avez
oublié les premiers de cordée et les
premiers de cordée ce sont les médecins
libéraux
les hospitaliers les infirmiers les
pompiers
les visiteurs d pad les visiteurs à
domicile et cela ne sont pas là mais ma
question
elle va être un peu différent c'est que
demain il ya des élections municipales
il y aura d'autres premier de cordée les
élus que ferez vous pour protéger ceux
qui tiendront les bureaux municipaux
envisagez-vous de reporter les élections
municipales